if you don't take any special steps most
new objects that you create will
delegate to the object prototype but
some of the special objects that you can
make in JavaScript have extra features
above and beyond the basic
characteristics of all objects arrays
for example have methods like index of
and dot slice those array methods are
stored in another prototype called the
array prototype since arrays behave a
little differently from objects the
array prototype even has its own version
of some of the standard methods like to
string the array prototype in turn
delegates to the object prototype so
that the non unique parts of an array
can be inherited from the object
prototype and not every single method
will need to be re-implemented here on
the array prototype notice that the
array prototype and object prototype
both have dot constructor properties
even though one delegates to the other
so what do you expect to happen when you
query an array for its dot constructor
property